I'm Andrew Gelman professor and
statistics and political science here
and I was asked to moderate measuring
scholarly impact the influence of
altmetrics
on a change in conversation the second
of four events in the research Without
Borders speaker series for the 2012-2013
academic year this event is sponsored by
Columbia's scholarly communication
program I just want to say that for me I
mean this this is um an important topic
for me and I think for just about
everyone who does scholarly research
because the only reason we're doing it
is to have some influence on the on the
conversation so and I think we scholars
tend to be very questioning about
everything except themselves so we
accept whatever whatever metrics are out
there and so I think it is very
important for people to be creative and
and to be thinking in a scholarly way
about how we think about scholarly
impact I'll introduce the speakers now
and each will speak for about 15 minutes
and then we'll have time for a
discussion and questions so please hold
your questions for afterwards but please
do me a favor and make a note of what
your question is because otherwise
you'll forget what it was when you when
you do ask questions we're videotaping
so use the microphone in the middle of
the room so we can hear the question on
the video now I'd like to introduce the
panelists they're Jason prema
is a PhD student and Royster fellow
studying information science at the
University of North Carolina Chapel Hill
since coining the term altmetrics he's
retired because once you've coined a
term I think that's really enough you
can rest on your laurels actually he's
remained active in the field organizing
off annual workshops on the topics
giving invited talks and publishing
peer-reviewed research he is also the
co-founder of impact story an open
source web app that helps scholars track
and report the broader impacts of their
research and I personally think I need a
web app that doesn't allow me to Google
my
self I think that would be my mean the
worst was when I did that and then and
then I found like all these people who
were attacking me and they were nobodies
so I didn't even need to respond I just
got upset sometimes he writes on a blog
at Jason cream org and he even tweets
Christie homes is a bioinformatics estat
Becker Medical Library at Washington
University in st. Louis School of
Medicine where she works to help develop
and support cross-disciplinary
initiatives her professional interests
include development implementation of
strategies for biomedical training and
research collaboration and research
networking open science and
understanding the impact of research
efforts she's director of outreach for
vivo and a member of the Washington
University Institute of clinical and
translational sciences tracking an
evaluation team and finally a Katelyn
app two wits tres ond is head of science
metrics at digital science a technology
startup company spun out of Nature
Publishing Group publisher of nature our
international team of developers
leverages the latest techniques in
machine learning to build software that
analyzes scientific publications to
support information products for science
managers and decision makers it's just
an undergraduate degree in philosophy
and history of mathematics and science
and a PhD in neurobiology from the
University of Chicago where she trained
as an electrophysiologist
so I wanted to talk really quickly about
what I think of as sort of a second
revolution the SCADA communication so
I'm gonna talk a little bit about
history about how we got here then I'm
gonna try and move on to talk about new
ways of communicating new ways of
measuring and finally how that could
affect maybe what I think of it like I
said is a second revolution so in the
beginning of SCADA communication was all
based on letters or any mean in fact you
know there's this the idea of a republic
of letters you know people at that time
called men of science would sort of
exchange letters from one to another and
that was sort of what scotty
communication was built on you used the
available technology but of course i had
a lot of problems right slow costly a
lot of duplication so in 1665 Oldenburg
published the first journal he said look
why don't we should gather all these
letters together let's put them all in
one place and then I'll just publish
them all together it's a lot less
duplication it's really handy um and
then I say about this was again it sort
of applied the best available technology
at the time the printing press to
solving the problem of district
distributing scientific information this
this revolution in scientific
communication promoted homogeneity of
outputs by which I mean the same sorts
of articles right like you want to try
and if you're running everything through
a printing press and you know you want
to bind it in a journal and distribute
it all over the place you want kind of
every product to be about the same race
sort of as terrorization or forward
model right it's like industrial outputs
particularly after World War Two but the
second revolution
I suggest will promote a diversity of
outputs right it's not hard to publish
these and more it's not expensive to
publishing anything anymore and so we
don't have to kind of press everything
into a cookie cutter sort of mold right
because we can sort of publish whatever
you want we can publish conversations we
can publish stories we can publish
analyses we can publish data coverage
all that stuff right so for example
conversation stuff we're talking about
right now rights being published on the
internet for better or worse stories
right we we write a paper that's sort of
a story about an experiment right we
didn't experiment Lu the story about it
the analysis we can publish so I I do
studies now where all of my analysis is
in our code right so I got my
statistical analysis I published out on
github if someone wants to fork my code
and run my analysis run all my
statistics on it they can it's easy as
pie right
and then find the data the data is
actually at the you know at the bottom
because it's the foundation of the whole
thing without the data there's kind of
no point right so we can even publish
the data sets we can budget all these
different sorts of items we can also
start to look at these different
different means of communication that
the web allows us to do so for instance
we got what graph that reference manager
is blog social bookmarking social
networks there's all these different
approaches researchers can take to
communicating so a good example of that
is Mendeley a mental a isn't sort of
thought of as a communication tool it's
a reference manager is quite similar to
endnote or refworks or anything like
that it's got 100 million 1.6 million
users 160 million papers very very large
database of papers but in some ways it's
a communication tool because there's
this sort of social aspect to it I can
show you my Mendeley library you can
show me yours
and there's an open API so that people
can query to find out if things are in
our Mendeley libraries another example
that I'm an excited I spend a lot of
time on this is Twitter so in one month
you know 60,000 issue citations from
Twitter to scholarly articles that's a
fair amount of activity in this
particular area we did a study on this
because we were curious you know
scholars see Twitter as a scholarly
space at all or is it really just a
space ways to talk about their lunches
right and what we got back was really
encouraging at least for someone who's
interested in new forms of scholarly
communication our participants saying
things like it's like having a jury
pre-select what will interest you
when I see things on Twitter sometimes
it'll change what I think are changed
when I'm interested in to me that sounds
very similar the kind of conversations
that scientists and scholars have always
had these sort of underground
conversation is these sort of what
people you know to solve oppression for
it is the invisible college but the cool
thing is we kind of maybe have access to
it now so another another study we did
on Twitter this is showing growth in
scholarly use of Twitter um I can get
more than the details to study the
question if you'd like but it's enough
to see basically all of these little
dots are individual tweets and you can
see sort of the slope of this graph
climbing is the number of Twitter
tweeting scholars gross all the code by
the way speaking of our car right so you
could generate this like my data's
online mykos online you wanted to go
down let just click a button and you get
this graph which i think is really cool
alright so simply talking about metrics
right I'm talking about new ways of
communicating we want to talk about
metrics how can we measure those well
again my backgrounds in history
like to kind of start with a bit of
history the idea of measuring
communication is a relatively new one it
existed before Garfield but Garfield was
certainly the one who popularized it
he created a science Citation Index and
what's really cool what's really awesome
and really transformative and and just
actually quite beautiful about this idea
of bibliometrics of citation mining
which is not exactly same as google
metrics but I use them interchangeably
for the purses this talk is that it
replaces expert judgments with
crowdsource judgments the problem that
Garfield was trying to solve is in the
post-war years the amount of research
was booming it was exploding and the
ways that that research had been
filtered up until then was basically
experts expert people would read the the
papers they would write out their own
little abstract they had an abstracted
service and then you would read the
abstracts but Garfield realizing
everyone starting to realize that this
was not scaling very well the amount of
research was it you know exploding and
the people smart enough and educated
enough to be able to you know with the
right expertise to create these
abstracts were in very short supply and
it didn't scale the same speed as the
literature so we said why not instead of
we asked people what's important why
don't we listen to what they say is
important already I think that's a
really important idea I really like the
kind of early transformative idea
he started mining the citation graph he
said well you know who's a better expert
about the scientific literature than a
guy who just wrote a literature review
about that field right I mean that's
sort of a you know you wouldn't have to
go ask you could just look you could say
what sorts of things did this person
cite and from that information you could
say this is this is the important stuff
in this field so we started so Garfield
started this idea of mining the
literature of mining the kind of
interactions people were already having
and using that to try and get a better
picture of the flow of ideas right
ultimately citation money is about
tracing the flow of ideas and ideas an
ephemeral thing right it doesn't it
doesn't have physical sort of you know
reality but we can we can measure its
tracks and that's a really cool idea the
bad thing about this is that it's only
part of the picture so you only really
track one person's influence or the
influence on one sort of person you're
only tracking influence on academics
because the only people who cite you
only really track the influence of one
kind of resource scholarly articles
because by and large scale er
are the only things that are cited and
then finally on the track one kind of
use using it to support a scholarly
article you're ignoring a lot of other
kind of uses like maybe using you know
clinical practice patents public
discourse all kinds of things yeah
absolutely yeah definitely and and not
even not only that but there's a whole
school of criticism of biglan metrics
that focuses on the the fact that it's
called the social constructivist school
in fact focus on the fact that these are
for these formal indications of impact
they're very intentional and because of
that they can also be used as a
rhetorical strategy so people often cite
to add credence to their own views right
like if I cite Einstein right after what
I say like maybe you know it gives it a
little bit of a Polish honor right or a
lot of times even worse if I know that
my advisor wrote something in a very
slightly related field I kind of have to
cite him right it's like sort of an
expected thing so there's this whole
network of formal relationships there
this is a known problem and since the
very early days have been metrics this
was a known problem so Garthim says that
Garfield himself said there's a lot of
useful journals that aren't being
reflecting the citation record bernal
great historian science really
interesting said science communication
scientific communication is really about
the personal stuff the underground stuff
the things what I sometimes called the
shadow system of scholarly communication
and then finally you know Combe who
needs no introduction says if we want to
track and merging research fronts we're
now it's not gonna be enough to just
look at the formal literature because
that's the stuff that rises to the top
years after the actual
intellectual the intellectual
contributions have been made so what's
concerning to me about the citation you
the approach of citing citation mining
for all its awesomeness and I think it's
very awesome is very beautiful is we can
start to confuse the kind of use we can
track with use and we can start to
confuse citation impact with impact I
think that could be a really bad thing
so my suggestion is that we start
looking a little bit more broadly so
bibliometrics mines impact on the first
scholarly web the web of citations right
at the web that predates the Internet
altmetrics mines impact on the next
skyla communication which is built
largely on the World Wide Web so I want
to show you a kind of a little bit of
framework here what kinds of things am I
talking about about tracking and why
would we want to track them so this
framework separates things into first of
all two different audiences so we could
have impact on both scholarly audiences
which citations do an okay job of
tracking right now but also on the
public and then we could also think of
impact in terms of levels of engagement
so sorry this thing that says scholarly
at the bottom should say viewed my
apologies so at the bottom they might
say viewed right that's not a very high
level of engagement it's not very
difficult to just click on something
look at him you're like okay Jason
premium he's talking with so I'm stupid
again I'll go somewhere else right like
that's pretty easy right you viewed it
there's no there's no engagement there
right but it's still useful right it's
still interesting idea right and then we
could kind of move up to Sade right like
I think it was good enough to save in my
library and then we can move up to
discussed not only did I save it I
wanted to talk to somebody about it and
then from there we can move to cite it
right not only do I want to talk about
it but I actually think it kind of
underlies the kind of work that I'm
doing and then finally all the way way
to recommend it right recommend is a big
deal because you're putting your
reputation on the line if you say hey
guys you all should read this thing
right that's an important that's a means
I probably really care about it um all
these uses are important I you know I
kind of have them stacked like this I
won't necessarily want to say weren't
necessary they say one is better than
the other but they certainly do
represent different kinds of engagements
so if you look in these cells you can
see that nowadays we actually have stuff
to put in all of these cells that we can
measure which is really cool to me right
discussions have always been a thing
right I mean we're gonna finish this
talk and hopefully you guys are gonna
discuss you're gonna think about it but
they just evaporate into air right they
go away those discussions but
increasingly those discussions don't
evaporate into air and when they don't
when they leave traces we can find
really cool things about them um so for
instance I'm not gonna go through every
cell of this table but a couple examples
right like so like I like citation right
we have citations for scholars that's
traditional spend happening awhile but
what about citations from the public if
something cited in Wikipedia surely
that's an impact that matters right a
lot of people go to a huge number people
go to Wikipedia their first source for
information if something is behind a
Wikipedia article it's a thing that
maybe is making a big difference in the
world I think that's really cool um you
know again like discussion could happen
on blogs Twitter I have Twitter in
public
because if you just sort of randomly
sample Twitter discussions it's going to
be most of the public you feel a bit
more focus of course and you look at
particular scholars then that could be a
source of scholarly discussion as well
so I want to show you something that we
built to do this how much time do I have
ten more minutes
great thank you much so I wanted to show
you this thing that we built so this was
built with the generous grant from the
sloan foundation and it's me and heather
pivovar who's active in the data
citation community and we said you know
this is really cool what if we built
something for scholars help gather you
know this information so the results is
this thing called impact story and it's
an open source project as I think was
mentioned earlier it's a nonprofit
project and our goal for this is to to
build something that scholarly community
can use to tell deeper broader and more
nuanced stories of impact moving beyond
just the impact factor moving beyond
just articles and actually telling kind
of the whole story so let me actually so
this is a live demo which means it will
almost certainly break but if it doesn't
it'd be awesome so this is the the site
these are some of the places that on the
bottom those some of the places that we
get information from so Scopus and you
know Twitter are pretty well recognized
Dryad is a data repository if there's a
knowledge librarians here you all know
across office so we kind of have a wide
array of different places that we search
for evidence of impact so if you wanted
to make one of these you would go and it
works now you can do this now you would
go to here and you would input your your
information so if you had a list of duis
or data set IDs or PubMed IDs you could
paste them in there if you had an orchid
you could paste it there anyone know
Orkut is awesome do you mind sharing
what work it is do you mind sharing what
work it is
exactly thank you yeah
and so um so you get this you know it's
kind of like I think was sort of like a
DOI for research all right it's like
serving an aggregate all your stuff so
if you paste your orchid in there it'll
get all your papers you could export
everything from Google Scholar which a
lot of times if you have a profile
there's a pretty good job of gathering
your papers all together or like said
you could paste them there so you make
this thing and you hit go and I'm not
gonna do it right now because it takes a
couple minutes because how to make a
bunch of API calls but I can show you
what you would get from doing that and
you get a page it looks like this and
there's a couple things you notice by
this first of all notice the articles
data set slides software and web pages
are all appear as first-class citizens
right I think in the future we're gonna
stop fetishize in the article as the
only legitimate means of scholarly you
know communication we're gonna start
saying this is one way to tell a story
about our scholarship there's a lot of
ways we do this we can do a dayss we do
slides all sorts of different things
obviously articles are better in some
contexts blog posts are better in other
contexts but eventually I think when you
start saying this is the medium the
message is what we should be caring
about so the other thing to notice is
that we've got these sort of badges up
here so this one looks like it's got a
lot of badges this one just looks like
it has a couple so let's investigate
that real quick so pyramid symmetry
transforms has been saved cited and
saved so blue means scholarly and green
means by the public we're gonna click on
this and take a little bit of a closer
look so saved by scholars so you
remember that table I showed you a
minute ago this fits
Mendeley into saved by scholars you see
a 67 to 85 here what that means is you
are in the 67th this particular article
is in the 67th to 85th percentile
compared to all of the other articles
indexed in web of science in 2007 the
year of its publication so the idea here
is you want to compare it to a
meaningful reference set for readers on
Mendeley is that a lot is it a little
who knows right so let's compare it to
something that we do know this random
sample of web of science indexed
articles from 2007 okay turns out here
in this range the range represents a 95
confidence interval of where your actual
percentile would fall so that's kind of
a cool thing right like kind of gives
you a little bit context so that you
don't have to just say oh you know it's
in Mendeley you can actually say you
know I'm doing okay I'm not like at the
very top but I'm in the top half that's
pretty cool
same thing with Scopus citations right
so two citations you know for 2007
article that's actually not that great
so that puts you in the 23rd 47th
percentile
I mean you know it's not terrible but
you know you're not really leading the
pack so on this other side we see the
public right so again I can say that was
bookmarked by the public not many things
do get bookmarked by the public it
turned out so one bookmark I actually
put you pretty high in the 90th
percentile so let's look at this one
it's doing a little bit better so this
one has a lot more metrics right so this
one 130 readers on Mandela that's quite
a lot more so that puts you the 97th
percentile which is pretty cool so
that's what you get when he's highly
badges if you wanted to look into this
and find the provenance of it you could
do that so let's say for instance tweets
who tweeted this I need some context
right - tweets is good it puts me in the
97th percentile because very few
scholarly articles actually get tweeted
but let's find out a little bit more
about so I'm gonna click on that and you
can see there's two tweets here when the
tweet says I would love to replicate
this for building systems so that sounds
like a scientist that's pretty cool that
as scientists is tweeting it and also
it's interested in replicating the study
which is the kind of thing we we would
like to sort of encourage and then read
about a below but here the key is its
encyclopedia of life which is a really
cool project that's um that's well known
and doing really cool things so here
it's not just random tweet so as tweets
by people whose opinion that's kind of
actually matter to us and it's a sign of
impact it's it gives us an ability to
tell a more data-driven story about the
impact of this particular article is
having here we see datasets datasets we
tell the same sort of we can give you
the same sort of information we can say
this dataset has you know 1,500 package
views well as 1500 a lot or little well
we can compare it to everything else and
the Dryad data repository where this is
we say actually it's in the 97
percentile this is a data set as being
downloads being looked at quite a lot um
it's even getting tweeted about which is
pretty neat right people are actually
wanting to talk about this data set
because it's that interesting what I
love is that if you compare you know
this this article in this dataset
without this information
the article is always gonna be better
right when it's come time to evaluation
well you wrote an article what's the
data set right but if you actually have
this data in front of you this impact
data the ability to tell actual
data-driven stories about this any of
these impacts you can say well this is
actually probably bigger deals in the
article right it means the 97th
percentile in all these particular areas
people are talking about got a
conversation right and so you can start
to actually compare things without
relying on sort of antiquated measures
like the journal impact factor so that's
the gist of impact story and I can show
a lot of other stuff but um that's the
basic idea
eventually oh yeah one other thing I
forgot to mention which i think is
pretty cool right now we just the the
reference set that we're norming against
against the percentiles is just a random
set of web of science but we have the
ability and we're gonna be rolling out
soon the ability to to customize
reference sets so what if instead of
comparing to just web of science we
compared to let's say a mesh term right
so you could enter in orthopedic surgery
and say compared to all articles written
about orthopedic surgery my article is
in the 97 percentile and the number of
times the scholars have saved it again
we're not saying that this is going to
replace citation you know scores we
think however it's a really important um
compliment because it gives us the
ability to tell this broader story
alright so back to presentation layin
why altmetrics why should you well I
kind of touched that a little bit I
think it's a little bit more fair um
being able to sort of show the whole
picture is really important funders are
increasingly asking for evidence of
social engagement from researchers we
can assess impact faster because right
so tweets happen like that right the
citation graph takes a really really
long time
peer review takes a really really long
time there's a lot of other advantages
but I think the most important one is if
we quantify impact if we really you know
and it's we're not quite here yet but if
we could imagine world in which we could
have this sort of spectroscopists mass
spectroscopy applied to impact right
bibliometrics spectroscopy where we
could actually measure every single
spectra right of impact we could say the
entire impact story all numerically
quantified if we can do that we could
teach machines what's important and
that's a really powerful idea that could
really affect the way that we
communicate as scholars now go through
this bit a little quickly
I think journals need an upgrade I think
journals are 17th century technology and
that's great but I think we can do
better I don't think we need to have the
best scholarly communication possible
using 17th century
right let's kind of move beyond that
generals are slow there's certain format
they're closed
the quality control is inconsistent a
lot of things make a pass purview that
never should a lot of things don't make
it past peer review that clearly should
and it's hard to innovate in journals
moreover we don't really use the web the
web was created as a scholarly
communication tool by berners-lee in
CERN right and today the web has gone on
to transform everything from the way you
know we we buy our groceries to
pornography it's transferring our entire
society and yet has not transformed
Scylla communication we still do the
same kinds of things it's still based on
the journal we just deliver the journal
and sort of a faster horse right that's
all the web is we can do a lot better
than than I think back in the day CERN
had a list of all the web pages which I
love right just like oh here are the web
pages like 200 right that seems silly
now but we're actually the same place
with journals we should have a list of
the journals like 25,000 journals right
what about 20 I'm gonna have like
250,000 rows 250 million right like what
ye even bother with journals why don't
just publish things so here's an example
of what I'm talking about um I wrote an
article called the decouple journal
which is sort of about these kinds of
ideas and I submitted it and I waited
and I waited and waited and I said look
this is kind of like you know I like
things sort of cutting edge stuff the
field is moving quickly right like could
we publish this like this decade please
I wait and wait and they were like well
you know so I said look I'm just gonna I
wrote it on a Google Doc can I just make
the Google Doc public and they said sure
to their credit their publisher um so I
made the Google Doc public and I tweet
it so this is a you know picture of the
girl you can still find it probably if
you girl it um so this is
pre-publication pre review copy tell me
what you think and I tweeted that to my
Twitter followers now there are not very
many people in the world who care at all
what I do right but almost all of them
follow me on Twitter which is pretty
handy because when I need to reach the
audience of people who care about what I
do I can reach them I have like you mean
1,500 people or something so I tweeted
this these 15 people say hey look ya'll
like this is what I'm doing you might
find interesting or whatever and the
response was awesome I got all these
people adding I found all kinds of
different references that I didn't even
know about that were added a thing I
mean that's your peer review right
instead of two peer reviewers one have
1500 1500 people were actually motivated
to go look at my my work and find the
errors in it make it better and not only
that not only doing at my peer review
that way I also got my disseminate
that way I don't even need the journal I
met a guy who was he's a big guy in my
field and um I was talking with you know
a little nervous I'm a graduate still I
can cuz I said you know kind of started
patience on my idea my second is like oh
yeah I did a couple journal I read all
about that already and I was like how
does this guy oh the Google Doc and so
it was it wasn't very difficult for the
thing that I had written because it was
you know at least a little bit
interesting to him to find his way to
him because I had these dissemination
channels the journal is again this
pre-pre web mindset right where its
industrial mindset we say well let's
bind everything together on paper and
we'll give this set of papers to all the
people who have this set of interests
but I don't need that anymore I can
reach the people who have my interests
very easily and if I can also add
altmetric to that right if I can add
metrics to say of all the things that I
publish or wrote this year here are the
ones that have found the most interested
audience here are the ones who have been
tweeted been discussed been cited right
here are the ones that have been used
who are the ones that have made an
impact I can put that on my see just as
well as I could put a journal article on
my CV right I mean like the the best the
best thing I've ever written at least in
terms of impact as far as I can tell
some has been cited like maybe 40 times
that's that's been really excited about
them of graduate students that's great
news for me it's in a journal with no
DOI a journal with you know pretty
minimal peer review but it's making a
difference in the world right so if we
can use all metrics to tell that story
and more maybe we can move past the sort
of slow sort of methodical approach that
journals offer us so I think this second
revolution is actually already started I
think that by the fact that the fact
that we can gather these metrics now
means that we're gonna have to use them
right once you can start seeing hey this
is how many people talk about this isn't
how many people save this this is the
different audiences that have interacted
with this product in these particular
ways once we have that information I
think it's impossible to ignore
I think the citation graph is exact same
way Garfield created the citation graph
not as an evaluation or measurement tool
he created as a search tool right it was
essentially a filtering tool but once
you had the data it was too useful not
to to use Peter Winkler says that he
compares it to Chekhov's gun he says
once you bring it on the stage it has to
be fired
so that
concludes my my it's a different job but
it's a job so that could was in a
presentation and I think we're waiting
on questions to the end right okay
awesome thanks oh okay great
um thank you first of all I'd like to
thank the organizers this is really a
fantastic topic it's very interesting
and very timely I'm also delighted to be
able to participate in the panel because
you know these are everybody's doing
things that I'm very interested in so
selfishly I'm very happy to be here I'm
also excited to share some of the work
we've been doing at Becker Medical
Library around kind of looking beyond
this idea of citations as Jason
mentioned and looking for true
indicators of impact and understanding
true impact and moving moving work
forward and how it can be measured so
just to put things into context I am at
Becker Medical Library at Washington
University School of Medicine the things
that I'll be talking today do have a
decidedly a biomedical slant to them
because that's what I do a lot of these
ideas though can be applied for
disciplines and we do have examples of
ways that other disciplines such as
climate science such as people in the
humanities are applying some of the
general principles that we've learned to
their own work and so we I encourage you
to think about these things with your
own perspective and certainly we
encourage you to let us know if you have
any feedback or if you have any ideas
because you know the work is only as
good as the least common denominator and
so if there are things that need to be
added or changed we're always open to
comments so as I mentioned we are
involved in biomedical research we do
things you know throughout the entire
spectrum of biomedical research we're
looking at not only bench discovery but
the efficient application of those bench
discoveries to clinical trial
to two standards of care and then
something that results in improved
health of the community which is I think
we can all agree probably the best
outcome of biomedical research so when
we look at tracking an evaluation and
trying to understand you know kind of
impact in this realm we look at
measuring certain things so certainly
we're looking at the amount of grant
dollars that are coming in things like
patents and then citations citations for
published articles are a significant
output and they're very easy to count
and so a lot of what we do has been
built around that however I think that
it probably goes without saying that
that may not be the best indicator of
the kinds of things that are really
happening and where the most impactful
work is happening things like papers end
up being placeholders or artifacts from
real work and as Jason alluded to you
know some of the most significant
interactions or modes of dissemination
for your work can happen behind the
scenes they happen at a conference when
you're speaking to a policymaker
they happen through email when you're
setting up a new collaboration so a lot
has been done on the topic of author
article and journal level metrics it's I
think it's very tempting to use these
metrics as a straightforward way to
assign value or worth to a researcher
for scholarly efforts or even trying to
rank journals and I think that these
metrics are very helpful in
understanding research efforts or
understanding the relative worth of
certain kinds of research outputs they
absolutely cannot be considered in a
vacuum so I think to understand the true
impact of research the metrics that are
derived from publication data need to be
supplemented with indicators that
demonstrate tangible outcomes so for
instance in our realm we're looking at
clinical implementation or benefit the
community influence on legislation or
policy and then certainly economic
benefit is a big one especially in this
post era funding time where we're
looking at the effect of stimulus awards
publication data alone does not
provide a full narrative of research
impact and it is not predictive of
meaningful health outcomes so we wanted
to think about going beyond the metrics
and what I'm going to talk to you for
the rest of the time today is a model
it's a library based model for assessing
research impact called the Becker model
the Becker model serves as a framework
to quantify and document research impact
based on research outputs and activities
and we also have a number of resources
available to help you do this so we have
reporting information we have guidelines
we have glossary Xand a number of other
things available including strategies
for enhancing research impact and we'll
talk a little bit more about these later
so I could not talk about this work
without talking about the two women who
are primarily responsible for even
heading down this path in the first
place so on the left you have dr. May
Gordon who is one of our faculty members
at Washington University May is the PI
of a study called the ocular
hypertension treatment study and had
gone to a meeting and had seen a poster
on citation reports and had come back
into the library and talked to Kat my
colleague Cathy star Lee who is
indicated on the right and said hey I
saw this I'd like to know a little bit
more about citation reports and Cathy
said no problem piece of cake we can do
that for you and so the question is you
know can we perform this citation
analysis of 26 peer-reviewed journal
articles generated by this oates study
and to understand how many times they
had been cited in subsequent
publications so I think that probably
this audience is very familiar with what
citation analysis is for those of you
who may not citation analysis is a very
traditional tool used in academia we're
looking at how many times a document or
group of documents have been cited by
subsequent publications you can consider
the publication's or these citations
publications are indicate indicative of
productivity and science or we think of
it that way and then the citations are a
way of judging qual
of that output and there's this inherent
assumptions that significant documents
will demonstrate a high citation count
but I think it's fair to say that these
numbers do not necessarily tell the best
story the numbers don't indicate whether
you have had a output that has gone on
to inspire further funding opportunities
it does not show outputs that are such
things as medical devices or survey
instruments or other things that are
real practical tools that are used in
the academic environment and beyond this
is a fabulous quote so it is no longer
enough to measure what we can we need to
measure what matters but the you know
the the here's the important part how do
we measure what matters how do we
determine that and how do we find it and
it is by no means an easy task
so we pas we put forward a hybrid
solution so we're looking at something
that takes two into account citation
analysis and moves it forward
so this Becker model involves tracking
research outputs that have been
disseminated and fused to locate
indicators that demonstrate evidence of
research impact so the Becker model is a
logic model it we focus on outcomes
specific to biomedical research bench
and clinical as I mentioned we do have a
number of people who are using the model
in their own environments and in their
own disciplines and they're making
adjustments as needed for those specific
differences the outcomes are grouped
into pathways based on stages of the
research process and we'll take a look
at that in a minute and if the indicator
service specific examples or indicators
that service specific examples of impact
are noted with outcomes this is an
outcome evaluation and if we focus on
outputs and outcomes and we if we think
it's especially important that we
include unintended effects to judge
program effectiveness because I think we
are all familiar with the idea that
sometimes the most wonderful outputs are
those that are the most unintended
so I mentioned pathways we do have some
specific pathways now this is highly
relevant to our particular environment
but I would encourage you to think about
your own environment so advancement of
knowledge is a big one we have clinical
implementation legislation and policy
enactment economic benefit and community
benefit so this is a screenshot of the
project website the URL for the website
is listed below as you can notice up in
the upper right-hand corner there is a
link to the model we also have see if I
can see me out of there it is there are
guidelines on how to use it
guidelines for enhancing research impact
and then information and further
resources that can support this kind of
activity you know we're excited to have
something that's based in the library
when we feel very strongly that the
library has a number of good resources
and also a good perspective of an
understanding of of information and
information structure and also we I
think by our nature most of us who are
in the library world really enjoy a good
puzzle and finding things and so it
seems like a wonderful marriage of
skills talents and resources so the
record model as I mentioned it where we
provide a supplement to publication
analysis and we do this in order to
provide a more robust view of research
outputs and understanding what's
happening in the biomedical research
environment in the Becker model we have
reporting templates we have a completed
report so that you can see what
something looks like when it's done
glossary zuv resources and terms
examples
lots of supplemental information we have
some readings so if you just cannot get
enough reading about research impact
we've got a number of things listed
there you know which can also help to
put things in perspective what we've
tried to do is establish a very
straightforward framework for
understanding the diffusion of research
outputs in activity
and guidelines to help you understand
and identify those indicators that show
true research impact and we're very
interested on doing this on a couple of
different levels we're looking at this
on the individual level certainly for
the individual scholar as well as the
core and institutional level as well
can you let's see okay okay um so and
let's see okay so guidance for
quantifying and documenting research
impact and then we also have a number of
strategies for an aunt enhancing the
impact of research so this is something
that's very very important to our junior
faculty our scholars and then certainly
even mid-career and and highly
established faculty are always
interested in enhancing their their own
impact within their field
so I mentioned evidence of research
impact so here are some examples in
biomedicine which have been separated
out by those pathways so advancement of
knowledge you know here we're looking at
things that cannot be found by mere
citation analysis alone so advancement
of knowledge we're looking at a license
agreement granted for the use of
intellectual property generated by a
research study so if you license a
survey instrument that's you know that's
meaningful that shows that that the the
knowledge that you've gained is being
applied in subsequent projects clinical
implementation a good way to know if if
something is being used in the clinical
environment is is if it there is a way
of documenting that it's happening in
the clinical environment so these CPT
codes are a good indicator of that
certainly in medicine if there's a way
of indicating that something needs to be
paid for so if there are billing codes
that's a really good indicator that it's
happening in the clinical environment
legislation and policy enactment we have
architectural guidelines for design and
current and construction of healthcare
facilities you will not find this in a
in a in a citation economic benefit and
communal community benefit as well so so
going back to dr. Gordon's Oats study
here are the things that we found as a
result of digging deeper past the
citations you can see we have
interventions continuing education
materials those CPT codes changes in
delivery of practice guidelines new
research studies so that's money coming
in to the institution based on that work
measurement instruments diagnostic
criteria new standards of care and
curriculum guidelines so these are all
things that are not going to be readily
discernible from citation analysis alone
however when you are that faculty member
and you're able to show that you know
this is the impact I've had in my field
I mean this is a very powerful story for
funding agencies for promotion and
tenure committees and so on so this is a
very lovely quote from May where she
which she included in the final report
to the NIH she said that she had
anecdotal evidence of the oaths study
impact but she wondered if quantitative
independent indicators were available
without the thorough analysis
recommended by the Becker model for
assessment of research impact we would
never realize just how far-reaching the
impact of our research has been so we
apply the Becker model you know
certainly to individuals to groups on
our campus and one of those groups with
which we have a lot of work is our
Institute of clinical and translational
Sciences or ICTs this is funded by a
clinical and translational science award
from the NIH to Washington University in
order to promote translational medicine
and both Cathy sarli and I are members
of the tracking and evaluation program
are tracking an evaluation or T&E
program is comprised of members who come
from a variety of backgrounds so we have
folks who are you know qualitative and
quantitative assessment certainly
bibliometrics network science surveys
and so on so we're all bringing in our
own background and our own expertise and
we're using the becker model to
understand how we can highlight some of
the work of our investigators and
understand what that true impact of that
funding from ICTs has been how does it
align with our goals for ICTs how how
does this work help us plan strategic
planning understanding changes or
developments in a field and so on and
also how do things align with the the
national consortium as well so again
biomedical research Enterprise so
everything is kind of biomedical in
nature and the things that we're
tracking we've tried to put into kind of
an easy-to-understand framework this may
be difficult to see from the back of the
room but what we've done is we've
actually mapped research processes and
outputs and the bottom in the root
system of the tree
um so we're looking at outputs you know
that are very common so yes we do have
peer-reviewed articles but we also have
things like software and datasets and
book chapters and blogs and wiki's and
all of those ways that you disseminate
you have outputs that can allow you to
disseminate the results of your findings
that information is diffused out into
the tree where we see these pathways for
research impact so these are these true
indicators that we do have impact things
that we saw in the earlier slide like
clinical guidelines legislation medical
billing codes policy enactment and so on
so this is not all sunshine and rainbows
this is not you know it is not something
that can be done if you have 30 minutes
to kill some afternoon it there there
are some issues so certainly it's not a
linear process it can be quite
frustrating at times because you do need
to go beyond the biomedical research
beyond those indices there is a time lag
between research discovery and
translational applications which is
something this translational application
is we're very interested in how long is
that time lag well it kind of depends
so you know you may not have the most
impactful work come out for years and
years after a study or you could have
something really interesting happened
early thereafter optimal timeframe for
starting assessment is unknown a
supporting documentation may not be
publicly available you know so I know
Kathy's made a number of calls you know
to a number of entities that you you
know to try and dig up this information
and sometimes it can be difficult to
establish a direct correlation from a
specific research output so you know I
think you know I'm not going to spend a
lot of time on this and you know I think
we all understand why this research
impact matter you know you want more
funding you want to be able to
disseminate your your ideas and have an
impact on your field you want to see how
other people are using your work and
using your ideas and building upon them
I mean that's the the true beauty of
scholarship I think and certainly a you
know at the more nitty-gritty level
tenure and promotion activities are a
significant effort so I found this
cartoon it was based on these ROI
calculations you've provided Davis I say
yes you can go to the bathroom so
sometimes it feels like that you know
you have to accomplish so many things
just to you know get the very bare
minimum things done so this this is
obviously an important thing research
impact is important so I mentioned we do
have some strategies for enhancing
research impact and we think improving
access and retrieval to your research is
the surest way to enhance its research
impact we have outlined several dozen
suggestions that have been divided into
three categories so we have preparing
for publication dissemination and
keeping track of your research and we
suggest repetition consistency and an
awareness of the intended audience to
keep that in mind when you're looking at
at your own work within your field so
there are a number of different ways
that you can build your pathways to
impact this information is available on
our website so I will not go into it you
can see that there are some good
Justin's certainly cultivate champions
I'm is a big one make sure and you know
take advantage of those human
connections be opportunistic you know
there's nothing wrong with this for
looking for opportunity and give
presentations and talk about your work
as much as possible in a variety of
different situations I also think that
we cannot emphasize strongly enough the
value of curating one's self so you know
we take care of a number of different
things in our lives and we may have
special collections we may have things
in our personal lives or even in the
library we have things that we are
caretakers of we need to be caretakers
of our of our scholarly reputation and
to me the most significant thing that
you can do is to be proactive so think
about this every time you talk to
somebody or give a significant
presentation write it down every time
you have a way of disseminating
information keep note of it I mean it
could be something as as old-fashioned
as a file folder it could be taking
advantage of story of impact story and
similar similar platforms to try and
understand how that work is being used
and I think that if your institution
provides research or profiles you as an
investigator or or as someone who is
supporting that work needs to make sure
that that investigators are putting
their best foot forward maintaining you
know up-to-date information about
themselves and you know most
institutions are moving to these and so
you may want to talk to your own
institution and see what they have
available there are just so that
everybody knows what I'm talking about
there are a couple of them are very well
used vivo which is something that I'm
involved with
there's also profiles at Harvard
University and Elsevier's Saibal experts
are some common ones so we do have a
number of resources available and we
have the original paper all the way back
in 2010 there are also some collections
of references available on Zotero
and the website and then I'd like to
take a moment to acknowledge my partner
in crime Kathy Solly who with whom I
have a wonderful collaboration we worked
together on a number of projects but by
far the research impact work has been
the most educational for me coming from
a non library background I've learned an
awful lot and also our Washington
University Institute of clinical and
translational science as well as the
Becker Medical Library and our
colleagues there if you have additional
questions you're more than welcome to
contact me and I'd also like to
acknowledge funding funding that I have
or with our Institute of clinical and
translational sciences so thank you so
thank you very much to the organizers
especially Katherine Pope and a
gentleman for moderating and the
scholarly communications program for
hosting this this has been very exciting
and one what I'd like to contribute to
the discussion of impact story and the
Becker model is to share some views of
how decision-makers in academia are
using scholarly metrics are consuming
scholarly metrics kind of a snapshot of
the state of life state of play and some
of the barriers to adoption of some of
these I think fantastic models that are
emerging so my presentation has four
parts but it's it's not very long don't
be afraid I'll stage set first I'm also
a someone who has a background in
philosophy in history by contrasting a
visionary physicist view of the true aim
of research with the the dilemma which
inevitably comes from the the building
up of knowledge and with which everyone
has to grapple I'll then layer on to
that dynamic the realities of the
practice of research which of course
involves money power and control and
then I'll drill down into specifics and
share perspectives from practitioners
who use metrics both traditional and alt
as well as peer based measures of
assessment and we'll look at what people
feel works what doesn't work what holds
promise and what are the either real or
perceived barriers to adoption and then
lastly I'll briefly touch upon some
ongoing work in the altmetric space by
colleagues at digital science so I'm
gonna apologize in advance for reading
some of these slides but I think that
they're reading from the slides but I
think that they're so well crafted and
honed and they really set the stage
perfectly and and articulating the
problem
so first the visionary physicists
articulation of the problem we have
inherited from our forefathers that keen
longing for a unified all-embracing
knowledge the very name given to the
highest institutions of learning reminds
us that from antiquity and throughout
many centuries a universal aspect has
been the only one giving full credit we
feel clearly that we are now only
beginning to acquire a reliable material
for welding together the sum total of
all that is known into a whole but on
the other hand it has become next to
impossible for a single mind to fully
command more than just more than a small
specialised portion of it any bench
anyone with a venture the author Ireland
Schrodinger of schrdinger's wave
equation Fame wrote wrote this in 1944
in his remarkable book what is life he
contrasts the practice of science which
is largely about unifying we unify data
perhaps in the context of an experiment
into a hypothesis we unify multiple
experiments into a theory and however of
course amassing all that data inevitably
leads to information overload which of
course I daresay has only exploded since
1944 we need metrics be they traditional
or altmetric or peer review because we
cannot be universally expert and layered
on top of this tension between the
unified vision and the realities of
being able to comprehend is of course
the realities the practicalities of
doing research which involves funding
and money in control and power as
beautifully articulated by the Princeton
sociologist Paul Starr and his work and
again I'll just read this one last slide
the dream of reason great opening for a
book the dream of reason did not take
power into account the jury of reason
was that reason in the form of the Arts
and Sciences would liberate humanity
from scarcity and the caprices of nature
ignorant and superstition tyranny and
not least of all the diseases of the
body and spirit
but reason is no abstract force pushing
in or exorbitantly towards the greater
freedom at the end of history its forms
and uses are determined by the narrower
purposes of men and women they're
interested in ideal shape even what
counts as knowledge and I think in the
context of what we've been talking about
today what counts as knowledge is as
relevant now certainly as it was in
several decades ago
so at the same time that we have this
tension between unity unity and
comprehension we have these virtues of
reasons these ideals of reasons and then
the realities of our narrower interests
you know more more respect more higher
rankings and of your Institute you know
more citations more influence and so
this is a bit of a stage setting but I
want to come down to the ground and look
in vivo as it were some of the
practitioners of research assessment to
see how people are grappling with some
of these tensions so we have actually
here a great contrast of those two those
two tensions where on the one hand you
have the ideal namely science is now a
vast global enterprise as articulated by
John Sexton the president of NYU in the
October issue of Scientific American an
exemplar of the ideal sort of expertise
and talent trumping national identity on
the other hand you have side by side
with it the inevitable rankings and
ratings that people are so fond of so my
team at digital science built the data
set and the visualization that
accompanied these articles and I think
they nicely contrast and compare those
those two tensions
and so you know people are very
compelled by my rankings and ratings and
and metrics and and and grapple yet with
with wanting to push forward with a with
more of an ideal so let's look at some
some of the practitioners of science so
in the course of my work at digital
science I speak with a lot of research
administrators and officers and decision
makers at scientific research
organizations Dean's and Chancellor's
and Provost's and chief scientific
officer and research strategy heads and
so forth and I'm interested in the
inputs which feed into the decisions
that these leaders make at their
universities and these are the power
decisions right these are allocating
resources capital investments Institute
building strategic and opportunistic
recruiting promotion and tenure
maintaining upgrading and staffing court
facilities information systems and so
forth now probably not come as a
surprise to you that citation metrics
have rightfully or wrongfully earned a
bit of a love-hate relationship everyone
uses them to varying degrees but most
people do so with at least some some
grudging their concerns falling into
these major categories I won't read all
the quotes but mainly the delays that
are by definition a citation is
retrospective it may not reflect a
reflect current faculty if it's in an
institutional level the lack of context
the fact that citations vary widely
across across domains citations for
radio astronomy is very different for
citations in the AIDS research community
and that it the focus is on quality
sorry quantity rather than quality and
of course a citation doesn't distinguish
between a negative and a positive
citation at its very core
looking at all metrics you know metrics
is so it's such a young and fresh idea
it has a lot of promise and opportunity
but also of course hurdles and so here
are some examples of what people what
people are grappling with in actually
using up metrics to make just
at universities and so these things I
think are worth reading so from a
Provost and in Massachusetts we hear if
someone is producing non-traditional
outputs we've heard we've heard a lot
about that with a becker model
non-traditional outputs at the core of
their work data set software we rely on
pure letters to evaluate the impact and
import of those efforts we are
essentially relying on alternative
measures of impact just as heavily if
not more heavily than rely on citation
metrics so this Provost is actually
putting peer reviews peer review letters
letters of support in the tenure Inc
process in the same category as as
altmetrics and that they're not you know
a traditional citation based measure and
from a chief editor at a nature of
research journal most people in the
community realize that impact factors
are not really a meaningful way of
assessing research quality and that an
article based metric will be useful but
altmetrics is a concept is not yet part
of the mainstream where it is difficult
to find senior scientists on social
networks in the first place and then
inevitably I hear alongside that but
this might be a generational issue the
phrase generational issue or digital
native inevitably comes up when I when I
hear people talk about all metrics that
we know it's coming we know that people
that are born digital are this is how
they communicate but we're not there yet
or many of our faculty members aren't
there yet and lastly and I highlight
this one because I think it points to a
potential way forward academic buy-in so
from a head of strategy at UK University
academic vine and tilt metrics as being
a serious tool will depend on the
robustness of underlying data and
academic judgment let me rephrase it
metric peer review I know peer review
and social media are opposite terms in a
way but getting those closely aligned
according to my view is the key to
success about metrics as a proper
research impact tool in addition to
being a nice-to-have tool by itself for
information only so I think that this is
a complementary to what we've been
hearing about the tools that are
available and that researchers and
administrators can use and how how
administrators are beginning to use
these tools and think about these tools
and the hurdles and the challenges so in
summary
I think that common concerns about
citation metrics we probably all pretty
familiar with them everyone is in
agreement that we need more a wider
definition of what impact means I think
that there's a lot of excitement and
promise around metrics it's real time
it's more inclusive and that's where
it's easier to track these digital
signatures and footprints of
conversations and of alternate outputs I
think some of the challenges are that
I've been hearing are really
understanding what the inputs are to
some of the aggregators and the
platforms and what if there's any kind
of hierarchy there apart from this what
you might have in your head that say you
know a Wikipedia citation is more
important than a you know some blog and
then lastly what are the norms and
interpreting that on those altmetric
data points and I think having kind of
reference reference data sets is going
to go a long way in helping people
understand how to interpret the data and
very very lastly I'd like to mention I
have a colleague at Digital science U
and 80 who's built a versatile tool to
measure attention at the article level
reflected by inclusion and reference
managers referenced in traditional media
and social media activity you can use
this tool for free by visiting altmetric
i.t and we have a number he has a number
of institutional and commercial clients
subscribing to his more commercial
venture altmetric comm which any
Institute can trial freely Ewan is he's
a computer scientist by training and he
spent a lot of time working in
laboratories and he really encapsulate
what digital science is trying to do
which is to use technology in a very
creative effective and inventive way to
make scientific research more efficient
and you can reach out to you and if you
have any questions about his his tools
by email or Twitter and so on behalf of
everyone at digital science thanks for
the opportunity to speak to
so now is your a chance to ask questions
um I I want to say I went I want to put
in a plug for blogging
I mean tweeting is is great I mean
somebody programmed my blog to auto
tweet the blog entry so that that's fine
I loved all three talks I had so many
questions and comments they have about
18 questions and I'm not allowed to ask
all 18 myself I think I'm gonna allow to
ask one or two cuz I showed up here to
moderate um also in case people are you
know afraid of going up themselves but
the only way to have 18 questions is to
write a blog post I can't write a
research article saying I have 18
questions about this I don't want to
send 18 Twitter's tweets so yeah it's
good to have multiple multiple
approaches I'm looking forward to to
writing the blog and then I'm hoping
that I get some comments I'd say also
that there is there is something still
missing in the world of blog comments
because it seems like there's a lot of
people who would like to comment but it
seems like such a big thing for someone
to comment on the blog it's it's
difficult but yet tweeting I don't think
it's enough I I enjoy when my blog
entries get tweeted because it makes me
feel better
but then people don't really add that
much to the discussion so there are I
know there are some online forums where
people can do the equivalent of a blog
comment and get credit for it they don't
get tenure for a blog comment but they
get +1 on it and all that those things
are great although I guess they're not
fully integrated I want to ask the
organizer about this are are the three
presentations going to be somewhere
because I need to link to them so I
don't want to say to link to them
separately be nice if they're gonna all
be in one place right okay great
glad glad to hear that so I'm I want to
ask just one of my 18 questions and the
rest of you can ask I'm in Jason
talked about he drew an analogy which we
hear a lot of which that things like
tweets or blogging or preprints are sort
of like scholarly communications and the
model is that the paradigm is is letters
or scientific articles I wonder whether
we also have to think of journalism as a
model and I mean that's not merely in
that commonplace idea that you know
blogs kill the journalism star kind of
thing but but also that if you look at
who are popular tweeters and bloggers
it's sort of a mix of let's say people
who are respected for their research and
have branched out in that area people
may be like Jason who are young enough
to have started there and are respected
in that realm but then you also have
people who are like celebrities who get
lots of followers and and also people
who are maybe they're the the good side
is people who might not be deep academic
researchers but are really good bloggers
really good tweeters they're really good
at that these these people who are
famous for linking who are blog
celebrities because they they can sort
of think well at that length even if
they haven't done a lot of scholarly
work um but that's I said then that the
sort of the bad part is then there are
people who are just trolls who basically
get a lot of hits and and like that and
in a way I just think that we have to
think of some of those people as being a
sort of version of a journalist people
who are trying to get a reputation by
entertaining or attracting attention
which isn't so horrible I mean people
click to a troll they must get some
enjoyment out of it it's um but I just I
wonder what you think about that like
that whether like I'm I'm just wondering
about because you're sort of continually
saying well this is the extension
instead of Isaac Newton you know writing
a letter and and so forth it's it's all
this stuff but if you go out into the
world of tweets and blogs
what you have was at the top of the heap
you have a lot of people who are
essentially journalists some were good
at and some are bad at it so we're
blurring the lines in other way so
wonder you feel the comment on that so I
think being a scholar is a job that
comprises a wide variety of skills one
of those skills and depending on the job
you might have some of those skills in
greater or lesser measure so some
scholars I want to look at you but and
then the microphone can hear you look
out um so some scholars I think are
particularly gifted communicators others
might be particularly gifted
theoreticians other might be gifted
methodologists gifted experimenters and
so on I often think of academic
departments in like that as a sort of
you know sports team like say a football
team I think unfortunately a lot of
administrators have fallen into the trap
of trying to build a football team at
all quarterbacks say well the
quarterbacks most important player on
the team clearly we want 11 of those but
that's not realistic I think we want to
have some researchers who are you know
getting published in nature all the time
I think we want to have some researchers
who are getting published in The New
York Times all the time who are really
good at articulating why the research is
valuable and why it makes a difference
most of what we do is funded by
taxpayers and my feeling I think a lot
of people share this is that we have a
responsibility to articulate that
clearly cogently and meaningfully to the
people who are paying for the research I
guess that has some commonalities to
German journalism but I think science
communication is I wouldn't necessarily
characterize it entirely as journalism
and I think it's great to be able to
build a football team that has you know
a quarterback and also you know a
fullback I think I want to build an
academic department that has a person
who's really good at experiments another
person who's really good at
communication that seems like a good
thing to me that's fascinating and
that's a wonderful response because it
definitely links into into that idea of
the challenge of hiring somebody who's
good at teaching for example or her to
communication it's so come to the mic
with your questions because if you don't
I'm going to keep asking my own
I knew that would get you know I just
wanted to ask the panelists if they
perceive a danger in advancing
altmetrics as a series of additional
proxies their reduction I think it's
it's part of that central tension
between wanting to participate and and
and and being able to comprehend I from
what from the conversations I've had
with administrators who use metrics it's
just it's it's just bloody necessary in
fact more so and biomedical research
than in in any other domain there's just
such a specialization you may know the
entire cardiology field but you don't
know infectious disease and oncology and
in order to have and and at the same
time there's a trend which I'm sure
we're all aware of and but don't one
really touched on their talk for there
to be interdisciplinary science right so
you have more of a drive more of a need
to be more of a polymath researcher and
so there are you know those tensions
exists and I think one of the advantages
of altmetrics is it helps connect
experts and helps connect them in very
casual human conversational ways less
formal more kerbside as is the phrasing
medical medical I need to Kerr have a
curbside with you and consult with you
about this issue it's outside of my
domain of expertise and I think
altmetrics helps engender more of
casual encounters among experts which i
think is good for interdisciplinary
science if I can follow on that I also
think that when you're looking at some
of these web-based services that allow
us to more easily aggregate information
about how people are using our outputs I
think that that can be I mean it's
incredibly helpful so the things that
I've talked about that you know you're
digging up are definitely not available
in the citation or in any kind of
citation information however how do you
know what rock to uncover how do you
know what rabbit hole to go down you
know and and these can be really good
indicators of where there might be an
interesting story so and can help to
supplement the story so I think that you
know everything is very complimentary I
do think it requires a kind of a
multi-pronged you know approach to be
able to accomplish this kind of work
yeah I don't have much that they're good
answers but um I would add I like they
use the phrase reward reductionism
because I think that's that's a key
concept in what we're doing here right
science as an enterprise where it has
the sort of conceit that we can measure
things that we can reduce things to
numbers and of course we miss things
when we do that and so I don't think
that all metrics or any kind of metrics
is going to tell the entirety or of the
story show the entire the picture in the
same way that science can't you know
tell the same story that a painting or a
poem or something else does but I think
it's also really powerful I think most
of us in this room probably buy that
measuring things and doing science on
them can be powerful and I think if
we're gonna do that and as Caitlyn
points out we really have to it's not
even a choice I mean these things are
gonna have to be reduced to numbers we
might as well do it well and the current
status is basically you know I'm we're
doing astronomy with with our eyeballs
right that's the impact factor what we
need to do is create telescope so I'd
create these sort of tools the equipment
that we can use to do actually really
precise exact useful broad nuanced
measurements I think we're at the very
very beginnings of that but it has a lot
of potential
was that what you're measuring is
actually a lot of discussion was
happening on that grad student yeah it's
a great comment and it's something that
we wondered a lot like you know when we
started doing this so we thought well
let's do a study for it so we did a
sample of five sort of representative
universities in the US and UK got all of
the people who all the grad students
faculty and postdocs who are associate
with those universities so at about ten
thousand people and then we searched for
all of them on Twitter we said well
let's see how many people are tweeting
and what what are they tweet about
sweded content Alice's in a sample of
the tweets and we found the generational
gap is not what one might expect in fact
grad students or we bumped grad students
postdocs and one non faculty active
category and not in fact they were not
any more likely to to tweet than faculty
were the only actually the big
difference that we found was that
faculty were rather more likely to tweet
about scholarly things so tweet about
their work we bought papers that sort of
thing so about 30 percent of mean and
quite a lot variance but the mean about
30 percent of scholars sweets were scott
of sorry faculty tweets were scholarly
and then only about 15% of graduate
students tweets were were scholarly so
actually fact they're a little bit
over-represented we didn't have data on
the age of the faculty so that's tough
to say but we were encouraged that we
also looked disciplines we saw there in
five sort of super disciplinary
categories there were not major
differences and the usage or how Twitter
was used so it's a really good question
at least in case of Twitter I found
those results encouraging the system
might be getting sort of a broader
across sample of the scholarly public
population yeah no no it's interesting
oh good question there's a poster of it
that's online it's pretty easy to find
it's on my CV and it should be published
in jaysis presently I was wondering
maybe Christy and Jason would talk to us
you might have something to say to
Theresa about the response versus of
actually trying to get faculty or
students maybe the difference there's
still a generation discussion obviously
but just the kind of responses you've
gotten kind of like on the ground
rolling it out it just I'm working with
a huge group of faculty and students
that I'm trying to convince of exactly
this so I'd like to hear about your
experiences doing that Thanks so yeah so
it's it's really it's so faster than me
talking about Twitter and these
discussions tend to end up there because
it's sort of like the litmus test it's
the the thing that people really stick
on because they it's so ephemeral and
unimportant and unprofessional for
people who aren't associated with that
community and for the people are so
sleek it's so central and valuable and
important and so it's a good question
and and I tend to find that there's such
a bimodal distribution it's hard for the
shoe size talk Ajay sometimes sometimes
I have something I found useful is
sharing the things that twitter has
accomplished for me so like being able
to sort of informally published my stuff
has been really useful I've created a
number of different I've gotten involved
in a number of different workshops and
what's the word panels panels I've
formed a panel on Twitter someone
tweeted like hey wonder your panel on
this topic and I was there so they're
both fond of stuff so if you're
interested in if your question and maybe
I misunderstood is is there good
evidence for why people might find is
evidence I was just wondering how you're
making it convincing maybe did you like
what when I heard that I was like great
I'd love to watch a video on you I would
show a video on you to every faculty
member I have to work on like that story
told that was great I was learning if
you do things like that or if you trying
it like the data visualization like
we're usually using data visualization
like that's so gripping I'm just
wondering like kind of things that kind
of catch their eye it's super field
dependent - right I mean like there has
to be a critical mass so in my field I
talk about scholar creation
a lot of people communicating so it's
really you know well computational
biologists they tend to be pretty um
computationally might in and so they're
pretty dense on Twitter digital
humanities like there aren't any digital
humanities people that aren't on Twitter
right right whereas other fields like
dentistry right they're not they're not
generally on like the cutting edge and
so if there's nobody there's nobody
there I mean it's sort of a network so
it's kind of like a diesel engine you
really need to get you can't just tweet
and then step back and say okay what now
what do I do
right right you have to have a following
and you have to it's it's really about
engaging with a community and as you
were saying earlier Jason having knowing
your audience and and you know being
able to reach out to that audience and
having audience feedback so I I think
maybe because it is so easy there's this
expectation well I just I just tweet and
that that's it that's that's just the
beginning it's it's actually you only
really get the benefit I think of the
entire network and the system if you
build up a following and you follow
other people holy and that that
activation energy puts some people off
yeah and I think it's also that's a
really good point it's a characteristic
of the medium to people think of it as
little blog posts and it's not and in
many ways it's not publishing at all
it's in conversational medium and so as
you say like if you go to you know room
like this right like a conference ever
people expect that they have to you
network right they have to work the room
they have to go talk to people sometimes
people won't want to talk on phone if
you were like but it's an active thing
you're trying to build conversations
around things and I think what's so
compelling interesting about Twitter
from a metrics perspective is we never
would have had a chance to listen to
something that low level that kind of
conversational activity that's what's so
exciting about a lot of posts are really
exciting too but they're not so
fundamentally different from articles
right you're making an argument you know
I mean it's more informal in there
totally awesome but being able to have
to have a conversation and have it leave
a trace is I think what's really
powerful about it mmm-hmm and so I also
wanted to follow up so I think you know
when we're looking at the various modes
of
disseminating one's comments or one's
work I mean there are a lot of things
there coming into play that you know
weren't around five years ago so you
know this is but one tool in our arsenal
I think you know your question that you
asked earlier about engaging your
faculty members you know I think it is
probably safe to say that the majority
of faculty faculty members do feel
pressure to try and put their best foot
forward and that's motivated by a number
of different things so it can be
internal pressures from the institution
or it can be external pressures from the
field and so if you can take advantage
of some of these things in order to
optimize who you are and itemize how
you're presenting yourself I think it
makes a big difference
you know I mean we work with faculty
members all the time and you know this
is very value we have a really great
reception on this kind of work so you
know and there are things that you can
get started with that aren't necessarily
I know I talked about I probably gave
the impression that one needs to put on
a hardhat and galoshes in order to get
this done you know but they're in places
where you can start even in the citation
databases that can provide really
meaningful information so if you look at
some of our some of our indices that are
available you can see you know who is
citing a particular paper but then you
can dive deeper and see you know what
countries are those citations coming
from what languages have those been
published in I mean are you
disseminating your information worldwide
or is it just happening you know in the
United States right you can I mean
there's a lot of things where you can
provide value add that people can
incorporate into you know promotion
tenure packets grant renewals Center
like annual progress reports for core
research facilities or you know virtual
groups and things like that right yeah
they'd love it I mean we've got all
these great tools in the library and I
think that people just don't actually
know that number one there are these
wonderful people in the library that can
help them use them and that there are
these tools and there
suppose all so yeah that's my plug for
libraries they're one of many probably I
heart library thanks for your different
perspective it was really great
hi so what extent do you guys think it
is important or feasible to do something
more than just count citations to
something but rather to do something
about the content so isn't it different
if somebody says this is the best
article I ever read or this is the best
thing I've ever heard - hey could you
believe this idiot published or posted
something like this and I'm particularly
interested in it because I'm a journal
editor and I don't like the
fetishization of journal articles by the
way I'm trying to get my readers to do
more offline and I you know people cite
other articles for the most ridiculous
reasons you know they could have cited
from a hundred and they picked their
their advisors article for example and
it's a psychology journal so sometimes
they're citing other articles for the
methods for the analysis is just broad
general background in the conclusion
they're citing it because they agree
with it or because they disagree with it
and these all just go into one big you
know citation or impact factor count and
I'm always started comparing to the way
the legal system does it so when a case
cites another case we know what it's
cited for is it consistent is it
inconsistent has it overrule the other
case is it just sort of in passing and I
kind of wish we had a way to integrate
that into what we have formally in you
know journal citations but could it even
be done where broadly thanks
I would imagine that in the legal
context it's very common for something
to be disputed or overruled but I would
imagine that in the scientific context
the vast majority of citations would be
positive not I mean I agree every once
in a while someone shooting something
down but it's got to be so rare like
would that matter that much you must
have some examples in mind I was
wondering if you could clarify well
there's lots of times when you come up
with with data that is it that are
inconsistent with somebody else's
research and and in fact I think part of
our problem right now is that that gets
ignored too much and not aggregated so I
think it's really important to keep
track of that even though in some
science is it's smaller than it is in
other sciences and some science is it's
greater but I think it's important to
keep track of what's going on yes so
it's really interesting field it's
really interesting area and a lot of
people have asked the same question
there's been several decades of work on
it so a lot of the earlier work was
about just trying to ascertain the
context trying to answer the question of
how many what what's what context you
people signed in so Garfield actually
some of his very first work in like the
60s let's answer just those sorts of
questions and so you had sort of a
typology you know that people have made
topologies and typically you know it's
like five to me at the most 15 percent
sort of negative citations the rest are
generally positive but as you say
there's also sort of things even where
it's cited something cite in the methods
section versus in the couny that's
really interesting so there's two sort
of approaches to that right one of them
is the Semantic Web approach where you
sort of say let's actually type the
citation let's say this is agrees with
disagrees with etc so there's really
cool work called the citation typing
ontology
and then another thing called Swan
citation typing on Taj is often
abbreviated CIT Oh Saito is socially
with David chaton but that stuff is
really cool it's a huge uphill battle
huge uphill battle to get people to
actually use that stuff it's hard enough
to get them just use like a standard
format right so my personal opinion is I
wish them the best but I'm not like I
wouldn't say super optimistic
the other approach is a text mining
approach where you sort of do there's a
lot of work in the commercial word on
sentiment analysis where people will
like you know you'll read tweets or blog
posts about coca-cola and say are people
saying good things or bad things about
coca-cola so not that much of that has
been applied to the scholar world the
biggest reason is because it's very
difficult to do text mining a large
scale because of closed access so as
more things become open access as there
are bigger corporate to use use on and
as some of the closed access publishers
start to allow limited text mining of
their corporate as well I think we're
likely to see you know substantial
progress on that front but it's a larger
problem some analysis I mean human
languages you know it's complicated but
it's great great question yeah I think
that it's it's even even with open good
more the trend towards more open access
analyzing sentiment in a scientific
paper versus coke you know tweets it's
just a whole other order of magnitude I
think really at this stage it we don't
have the technology we don't have the BI
I do a lot of text mining my team does a
lot of text mining and things that you
would think are solved we struggle with
are hard in normalizing institution
names something that trivial is a hard
problem so I think that I think we will
get there but I think we're fairly far
away from having the sophisticated
algorithms the algorithms with
sufficient sophistication to tackle
understanding the nuance and the
subtlety of the the the citation I think
at this point it really does come back
to people and having a human being
interpret having an expert interpret
that that work which and and and thus
again I think that one of the advantages
of altmetric one of the great services
it provides to the scientific community
is less so the numbers and more so the
connecting of experts
well before someone runs out there I
have a question I want to ask for
Christie and Kaitlyn and okay in
demography there's something called the
age period cohort problem which is that
if you're trying to study behavior if
you want to compare people at different
ages they have different cohorts right
because because I was born before you
were so but also I'm older but then one
way to compare people like who are
different ages would be to compare the
young me to the middle-aged me now word
the same cohort but we're comparing
different periods so the young me didn't
spend so much time blogging right so
it's impossible to do that now I'm
thinking that in I'm particularly asking
Christie and Kaitlyn because both of you
talked a lot about the human connection
what do people want for out of this what
are people's goals which is actually
very interesting from another standpoint
which I can blog about later but if
there's a big it seems like a very hard
thing for us to understand I wonder if
we might be confused by the nature of
our subjective data for for two reasons
and one is I was just thinking well as I
get older I'm less interested in in
publishing in journals and part of that
is journals are less important part of
it is I just sort of I've done that
already I wanted to do something else
and it maybe if I were at the same age
forty years ago I also would have
started to lose interest in publishing
journal conversely I wrote a textbook
when I was thirty and one of my comments
made the charming comment my colleagues
one of my colleagues made the charming
comment that isn't that what people do
when they're too old to do research and
I said I already am so but then the
other thing is that we have a Democrat
I'm not an even demographic transition
but there's a equivalent of the baby
boom but more so there's more and more
researchers most scientific researcher a
lot more scientific researchers are
young than all the middle aged and more
middle-aged and old so there's been a
huge change in science and it's
continuing
to change so I just wonder whether you
have reflected upon that in your in your
analysis the idea that like people are
doing stuff they didn't do before part
of it might be that they have different
goals but maybe it's also that people in
general the field as a whole is getting
older and more mature and even if Google
etc had never existed maybe we'd be sort
of getting tired of trying to publish in
journals so so these are really good
points and something and these are
things we see every day
because we'll be working with different
people at different points in their
career trajectory and you see them
emphasizing different things you know I
I will say that we do you know we do
have primarily we have our younger
people our junior faculty and scholars
who are interested in utilizing some of
these different modes of dissemination
for putting their best foot forward
certainly but I mean this is also
happening with our more established
faculty members although not at the same
right I I would like to throw another
variable into the mix which is the
changing requirements by funding
agencies as well so in the last couple
of years we're now seeing in like grant
renewals they're asking for evidence of
impact you know when we're submitting
renewal applications for various grants
we're helping people put together
stories and put together highlighting
how their research has made a difference
and it's it's the difference that goes
to motivations that a taxpayer might
have and where it's the motivation
toward highlighting improved you know
clinical care or something like that but
I you know I mean we're seeing kind of a
wide range of people you know I've
worked with younger people on our campus
who are very very into the traditional
way of the way things have always been
done and you know and it's delightful
when we get someone who is very
established in their career and really
doesn't need to be
need to be more impactful and and there
they're excited about these new ways of
judging their influence in their field I
mean it's it's it's very hard to pull it
all apart and you know when we're
looking at trying to compare different
cohorts and understanding like for
instance we do a lot of social network
analysis of our research teams and so
trying to pull out cohorts that we can
use for valid comparison how much
happens because our world is changing
around us and how much is because of you
know people being part of a particular
group it's very difficult to pull out I
mean it is it's very difficult
yeah I'd echo that that a lot of it's
probably about the drivers and that
faculty members that are pre-tenure have
a very specific driver and so their
behavior is going to largely be is going
to conform to the standards that that
particular research university has has
set forth and and those are moving at a
glacial pace those standards those
tenuring and promotion standards of
threshold for for for excellence they're
glacial it's a very conservative set of
criteria and so I think that you could
argue that universities could do more to
to to to encourage and support faculty
members to be more communicative by by
zeroing in on that one very very
profound and influential driver of
research on building off of what Caitlin
said you know I do know that there are
universities that are now starting to
you know in their promotion and tenure
guideline language beginning to talk
about things like
collaborative work so you know just a
few years ago collaborative work you
know with something you might have done
on the side if you had time but you
really needed to be able to show first
author or last off their position on a
paper and now you know we have these
very large research teams coming
together around genomic medicine
initiatives you know and a host of other
things physics you know it's a highly
collaborative field so that's something
that we're seeing and I think you know I
think that that's good there's
definitely been an influence on team
science you're seeing it coming from
many of the larger funding agencies
trying to support that kind of
collaborative approach and putting in
place education and training efforts
around those ideas so I'm optimistic oh
thank you I'm last chance to ask I won't
put you through any more right now thank
the speakers